[Música]
hablamos de economía en directo américa
con jorge hurtado jorge y vamos entonces
a empezar a hablar del impacto de la
crisis ucraniana en las materias primas
así es raúl y es que los precios del
carbón el aceite el aluminio llegaron a
su mayor subida semanal desde 1974
mientras los precios del petróleo y el
trigo están en sus niveles más altos en
varios años para darnos una idea los
precios del aluminio en la bolsa de
valores de londres han aumentado un 30%
desde que inició este año mientras que
los futuros del trigo de eeuu subieron
un 25% solamente esta semana hay
preocupación en los países de medio
oriente y áfrica del norte porque prevén
un duro golpe en la subida a los precios
de los alimentos por esta guerra que
aunque esté muy lejos de ellos a través
de la inflación y el aumento de los
precios pues se acerca cada día más
veamos el reporte
casi todo el mundo está comprando harina
en estos días en el líbano yemen y
egipto
estos países dependen de ucrania y rusia
para obtener su trigo con las
exportaciones bloqueadas en los puertos
ucranianos los precios han saltado y la
gente está preocupada
debido a la guerra entre rusia y ucrania
tenemos miedo de que haya escasez de
harina y trigo pero dios mediante no
sobre pondremos a estas dificultades el
pueblo yemení es sabio
los precios ya se han disparado pero los
importadores y distribuidores dicen que
el miedo de la población ha empeorado la
crisis porque la gente ha estado
agotando la existencia de pan nuestro
país tiene una guerra y los precios son
fijos porque sufrimos esa guerra pero la
guerra entre rusia y ucrania ha hecho
que la gente aumente la demanda de trigo
tanto que algunos comerciantes
aumentaron los precios debido a la gran
demanda en egipto casi un 90 por ciento
del trigo viene de ucrania y rusia el
líbano mientras tanto tiene un problema
específico en el pico de su crisis
económica ya no puede almacenar granos
porque sus grandes hilos fueron
destruidos por la explosión que devastó
el puerto de beirut
cambie
las cantidades que tenemos son
suficientes para un mes porque están en
molinos hoy no hay reserva nacional sin
los silos los precios de los alimentos
ya se han disparado en años recientes y
millones son vulnerables y sufren de
hambre mientras los gobiernos buscan
proveedores alternativos la panadería se
han comenzado a racionar para que todos
los hogares puedan tener su parte
jorge y este aumento de precios o cómo
podría impactar en nuestra región
nuestra región latinoamericana es un
tema bastante complejo porque a pesar de
que varias economías se pueden
beneficiar del aumento del precio de las
materias primas y el petróleo el mayor
desafío ahora y seguirá siendo es la
inflación por ejemplo argentina que es
uno de los mayores productores y
exportadores globales de granos y
derivados sacará provecho de los altos
precios del trigo y el maíz pero debe
hacer frente al efecto dominó de este
conflicto escuchemos qué dice al
respecto leonardo pieza el director de
la consultora fti consulting
la situación de argentina en contra en
forma ambivalente por una dos puntas
seriales de la famosa y por el otro lado
y montadas segundo tanto el ministerio
de economía del año 2021 argentinas por
todos por 39 mil millones de dólares e
importó gas en ese mismo período por 6
mil millones de dólares el principio del
número dirían que el efecto del
conflicto no sería tan perjudicial para
argentina pero cuando vemos algunas
situaciones que están pasando hace que
la situación sea preocupante por el lado
del sector agropecuario la argentina
estuvo una merma en la área sembrada con
15 un 20 por ciento esto diagramará en
la economía real y doméstica y también
jorge las autoridades en brasil dijeron
que vigilan la volatilidad de los
precios del petróleo y también el gas
así que bueno lo dijo en un comunicado
en conjunto la cancillería de brasil y
el ministerio de minas y energía brasil
anunció que se sumará a la iniciativa
adoptada por los países miembros de la
agencia internacional de energía de
liberar 60 millones de barriles para
tratar de estabilizar el mercado para
seguir produce cerca de 3 millones de
barriles de petróleo por día y afirmaron
que continuará en los diálogos y
coordinación con sus socios comerciales
en especial con el grupo del g20 el
presidente de brasil jair bolsonaro
defendió el accionar de rusia contra
ucrania y criticó el presidente
ucraniano bolsonaro se reunió con putin
previo a la invasión craneana para
fortalecer los lazos comerciales
'jorge gracias por toda la información
económica nos vemos más adelante con más
pasamos ahora a ver nuestro reportaje el
día
[Música]